a new super stretchy polymer material
from Stanford University can heal itself
at room temperature and could lead to
self-healing electronic circuits as well
as electronic skin for prosthetics and
robots and EPFL scientists have proposed
a new model for understanding how the
brain processes information suggesting
that stimulus is processed unconsciously
and then perceived consciously in 400
millisecond intervals called time slices
Vsauce Kevin here this is mind blow
Tesla phoresis causes nanowire to
remotely assemble using a force field a
Tesla coil designed by researchers from
Rice University oscillates positive and
negative charges in each carbon nanotube
causes them to chain together they
created a functioning circuit connecting
two LEDs that is powered by the Tesla
coil feel it's the first time electric
fields have been observed moving matter
on a large scale and they believe this
could lead to breakthroughs in
regenerative medicine and artificial
systems that can self-assemble without
physical contact skin haptics uses
ultrasound to provide tactile feedback
for interfaces on your hand the array
emits ultrasound through the back of the
hand to create sensation in a focused
point of the palm the prototype is
admittedly large but they're already
working on a significantly smaller
version with the plan one day to
implement this alongside flexible screen
technology to turn your hand into an
interactive electronic device which
could pair quite nicely with ultra
flexible organic photonics skin the
smart East skin system developed at the
University of Tokyo allows for a two
color logo display as well as a red
seven segment digital display along with
being a display that's one order
magnitude thinner than the epidermal
layer of skin the plan is for this to
also monitor health by measuring oxygen
levels in the blood
challenges to further development
include protecting the e skin from being
destroyed and finding a power source
like flexible batteries or the energy
from harvesting your body heat a neural
bypass is allowing a man to retrain his
paralyzed hand in 2014 researchers at
The Ohio State University Wexner Medical
Center implanted a chip in Ian Burkhart
brain an algorithm that translates his
thoughts into impulses for a sleeve on
his arm bypassing his spinal cord in
less than two years of working with and
training the system is gone from picking
up a spoon to playing guitar hero and
swiping credit cards and they're
confident this system could help stroke
victims as well as differently-abled
people in the future we may be one step
closer to functional smart clothes
researchers at Ohio State University
were able to embroider circuits into
fabric with 0.1 millimeter precision a
perfect size to incorporate sensors and
memory devices into clothes further
development could see smartphone
antennas in shirts performance
monitoring sports equipment and even
bandages that can tell your doctor how
to is healing the best part is that the
embroidered wires feel the same as
typical thread mind blow 43 back in June
2012 featured jogo bot a drone designed
to accompany joggers by using tracking
markers on a special t-shirt while
Scottie Oh is a new drone that
autonomously follows bikers and joggers
while avoiding obstacles without
requiring special clothing it uses a
multi-camera array and onboard computing
to map and plan its navigation rather
than simply reacting to things it might
crash into while this is just a
prototype their goal is to bring it to
consumers and in their words create a
magical experience finally check out
this new augmented reality demo from
magic leap this video is shot through
the mixed reality technology
I'm going to leave you with an animation
from NASA on the future of space
exploration and as always thanks for
watching fingertip shopping will be one
of the many homemakers conveniences this
video console will be channeled into the
store of her choice there a camera will
scan a display of wares which she will
select by push buttons what the wife
selects on her console will be paid for
by the husband at his counterpart
console all bills and transactions will
be carried out electronically also at
his disposal is an electronic
correspondence machine or home post
office which allows for instant written
communication between individuals
anywhere in the world